[Music]
hey what up y'all thank y'all for
joining me for another episode of
flatline live here at thick boys studios
man i told y'all to keep bringing that
fire and y'all hitting me with them
jokes man the roasters are getting
better and the youtube jokes are getting
better that's what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about man all right so i'm gonna read
about
seven of my favorite jokes that i saw on
youtube and y'all let me know what y'all
think
david was the kid who peed in mcdonald's
play land
i actually did bro i actually got bit by
a scorpion in the mcdonald's playlist
one time in the ball pit actually
davis still has a blanket covered in
[ __ ] things and lemon peppers that is
are you spying on me
because that's exactly what's on my
blankets i love lemon pepper wings
david keeps his brain so he doesn't look
like carl winslow you son of a [ __ ]
david looks like kenny ate kale
it's my favorite show growing up
david looks like four richard sherman's
david looks like he grew up on flint
water did you you racist [ __ ]
you're racist that's racist sir
david looks like he keeps ringing pops
in his pocket
what if i just pulling out right now now
i'm sweating
[Laughter]
all right man we got a little news for
y'all right quick man uh the world is
going crazy
uh this one shorty said
that
she's a college student she said she's
allergic to sex she's 18. she said semen
can leave her with temporary muscle
paralysis and excruciating pain if she
doesn't use condoms
[ __ ] just say you're gay
that sounds like an orgasm to me every
girl who has an orgasm is temporarily
paralyzed
the [ __ ]
i bet your pronouns are she he they it
could would should [ __ ] like
this is what girls have to come to like
you you can't say i'm gay anymore so you
got to say i'm allergic to semen and i
have paralysis if i have unprotected sex
[ __ ] they just cured hiv i'm never
using a condom again get that [ __ ] out
of your head it's over with kind of like
covert it's over with we raw dogged and
raw dog in the air for the rest of our
lives
they just cured hiv and this is the
excuse you want to have you think you
can really make a guy wear a condom now
all right but whatever man we're gonna
get into these ropes man let's see what
y'all got
david what up man what up boy you look
like a personal stylist for werewolves
[Laughter]
can you sing me a reuben stuttered song
well you look like uh you look like
leaving the beaver in romania
[Laughter]
[Music]
telemundo jerry seinfeld look at that
that's a good one right there your
gloves are your shirt made out of same
material
your shirt your shirt trying to keep it
sexy your shirt made out of old race car
tires
that [ __ ] got a dale earnhardt
tire on his chest bit
tony made it
yeah boy
he's sick
you got that got the jail got that the
freaking mexican gel in my hair [ __ ] my
hair ain't going anywhere yo that's
crazy bro you can you can get on the
roller coaster look the same when you
get off
[Laughter]
well at least i can fit on one though
huh
[Laughter]
you drink your water at room temperature
because you scared of ice boom [ __ ]
who gonna get that
there you go ice the people that take
illegals away that's it yeah
there we go i gotta explain it
what's up
what's up [ __ ] is that a sailboat
behind you
what the [ __ ] are you getting cell phone
oh cause of the [ __ ] bags what is
that bro you the [ __ ] you got going on
you you calling live from the freezer
part of a grocery store [ __ ] your ass
bogus is [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you're in a wood shop
class [ __ ] you bout to make a stool
ain't it your sweater look like we both
work together man where you work at
uh
right now i'm just uh working from home
man just uh trying to
get a job and all that [ __ ] that's
pretty embarrassing that i just told you
that i'm mexican without a job ain't
that a [ __ ]
i'm not mexican so that's the difference
what are your friends right what up
nicaraguan and nicaraguan you're a
nicaraguan
yeah yeah i'm nicaraguan dude
yeah man i know i know we worked
together man i was i was a [ __ ] i
don't know how to do this [ __ ] but
definitely man i i definitely think that
uh you are all you are known to all
seasonal employers as david
lazy i'm trying to understand the [ __ ]
going on what just happened you said we
worked together
bro oh
oh you
i thought you were saying the easter
speech [ __ ] that [ __ ] was emotional you
had your head down you had zero
confidence in what you said [ __ ]
act like you're walking up to a taco
truck about to order some kanye inside
of tacos [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ]
yeah bro you look like you do kids bop
dj [ __ ] like you got all the rap
songs with no curse words in it
every time you put on a bathtub around
your waist you look like e honda the
street fighter
you don't even know who the [ __ ] that is
you're like older than me come on man
huh come on eat honda
how old are you bro
i'm 32. yeah you got the face of a 42
year old pedophile you nasty
[ __ ]
yeah yo how do you think of my [ __ ]
glasses
hey you got a carhartt sleeping bag on
man i'm tired i'm tired of roasting your
goddamn uh senior citizen penguin
looking ass
yeah bro that's my that's danny devito
look at daddy defeated this [ __ ]
you look like that tv show the critic
[ __ ] yo ass out here boy
you look like the [ __ ] that soul philip
seymour hoffman the drugs he died on
it's a little dirty ass out of here
that way boy got gray hair and a nose
ring oh freaky old gay [ __ ] boy get
your little stupid ass
somebody said [ __ ] the heretics put your
rubber band from the hoagie on your head
yeah bro i know you smell uh i know you
smell seats when people get up and lick
toes you just nasty bro
you're so dirty on you like you'll go
into a bird nest and crack all the eggs
little stupid [ __ ] boy
how you like a sunny side up or what i
don't know dawg your ass dirty bro
you're a [ __ ] paw patrol you're a
pervert bruh
[ __ ] don't even gotta cook em
you like a senior citizen toucan yo ass
out here
same placard hanging up in my car
[Laughter]
[ __ ] about to repeat after me
probably want a cracker
you change your name to paulie
well you know as big as [ __ ] dog
y'all know it's big boy you can smell
the [ __ ] feelings your nose is big as
[ __ ] boy hell yeah it smells like you
want a number four yeah you can smell
when a [ __ ] having a bad day you know
you smell like you have a headache
[Laughter]
a little big nose as somebody here boy
you got a job working at the police
station sniffing out drugs at the
airport little big nose uh
got me slacking
yeah boy yo that's always slacking big
nose out you look like you got on one of
them uh fake disguise mask with the
glasses in the nose
that's what that [ __ ] looked like boy
your nose looked like you come off with
them glasses
your nose do not belong to your body you
take them glasses off it's just a hole
right though
from a coal mine look at your little
dirty ass a coal mine you like
a cigarette you might
my basement my bedroom yeah you down
there [ __ ] a mannequin a little nasty
so so what are we doing here a little uh
you probably gotta you you probably
gotta blow it you probably got a blow up
doll in a sleeping mat in a sleeping bag
i know it's called punch commercial it's
it's cold and damp down there
well you brave [ __ ] down there the
end they life [ __ ] you nasty
you probably got a vcr you got a vcr
hater
no
xbox one
you look like you're allergic to
sunlight yo that's crazy
uh i'm a night owl i like tonight
you look like it oh twilight look at the
[ __ ]
your skin shine in the daytime no you
got scales i can tell boy
yeah maybe
so you gotta uh
you can't be in direction here is this
the uh
the uh the part from
charlie chocolate factory where they eat
the blueberry
yeah that's good what's going on you
getting there you're getting there
that's the whole time yeah a little sock
puppet looking ass [ __ ] get your
little dirty ass out of here
yo ass look like a dingy basketball sock
[ __ ] get your stupid ass out of here
what's up bro
what up your name sounds like a magical
spell balthazar
you say that [ __ ] three times a
[ __ ] turn into a cat
hit me with your best shot what you got
hit me with your best shot let me see
what i got um you look like the plug for
illegal snacks
you look like you won an arm wrestling
competition in puerto rico
you look like you run a trap house where
they make chicken sandwiches
and you look like that handicapped boy
from the burger king ass back in the day
the one who's in a wheelchair
oh i never seen that [ __ ] yeah knight is
baby [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you look like you're competing for
world's highest blood pressure
you look like you sell illegal fireworks
i got what you need
burger king put a picture up of you for
customer of the month
how you getting somewhere dawg
you probably got a room full of cacti in
your house
little dirty ass jackalope looking
[ __ ]
last time they did a drive-by on you
they shot you up with insulin
[Laughter]
that's a good joke [ __ ] hey he
would have done it let's hear what you
got
you're the three-time world champion at
dodging child support
[Laughter]
i wish i was i hate paying child support
you every [ __ ] all right bro
appreciate you dawg that was fire man
that's what the [ __ ] i like
hey man y'all came with them jokes a few
of y'all flame me up bro you never gonna
lie y'all hit me pretty hard but look
though i'm not gonna be here next week
i'm on tour so you got two weeks to
prepare to hit me
make sure you writing practice your
jokes on other people and then come back
at me and hit me very hard man but look
though still put those comments in the
youtube section because i will be
reading my favorite comments off at the
beginning of the show and thank y'all
for tuning in to another episode of
flatline this your boy david lucas man
peace
you